صحيح في شمال القطاع هناك غارات عنيفه جدا
في هذا المكان ومختلف الاماكن علما انها
تعرضت لعدد من الاحزمه الناريه منذ منذ
ساعات ولا نعرف حتى هذه اللحظه ما هي هذه
الاحزمه او اين وقع القصف بسبب صعوبه
التحرك من مكان الى اخر لكن وصلت مناشده
الى مجمع الشفاء الطبي بعد حصار قوات
الاحتلال عماره عنان الواقعه مقابل برج
الجلاء الذي قصف في داخله مقر الجزيره عام
20211 هذه العمارات هي خمس بنايات تتواجد
بها مجموعه من العائلات حوصرت وضربت
وتعرضت لعقاب جماعي وايضا ابلغت ان هناك
ما يزيد عن 15 شهيدا وما يزيد ايضا عن 30
اصابه محاصره في هذا المكان هذه العماره
ايضا تقع قرب البنايه التي قصفت بها ال
سالم صباح اليوم وارتكبت مجزره بحق ه
العائله هذه العائله واان معنا احد
الناجين وهو الناجي الوحيد من هذه العائله
الذي بعد ارتكاب قوات الاحتلال المجزره
التي راى صورها الجميع قرب شارع الجلاء
مقابل برج الشوه وحصري الان هذه الكشوفات
التي تحملها العائله نسمع ونقرب الصوره
اكثر هؤلاء كلهم شهداء في داخل الكشفات لو
تتحدث اكثر عن هذه المجزره في الليله
الماضيه تم تجديد الحصار على المنطقه ولم
اقدر الرجوع الى البيت تم محاصره يا وقمت
في دخول احد المدارس والنوم بها لمده ثلاث
ايام لم اقدر ادخل الميت م مره اخرى ارجع
له انا خرجت من البيت انه نجيب ملتزمات
للبيت وعننا اول شيء احنا كنا ساكنين في
الشمال طلعنا على حسب تعليمات الجيش انه
نطلع شارع
الوحده وصلنا شارع الوحده لقينا بيت
استاذنا من اهله رفعنا اول ما دخلنا البيت
الريات
البيضاء وعائلتي وكل العائلات اجت عائله
سالم
طبعا اليوم الصبح قدرت اتحرك ارى المنزل
لقيته كله مدمر لقيت احد الجيران بقول لي
في عندك العيله في الشفاء طلعنا 16 اصابه
ومنه وتو قبل قليل استشهد ايش على اللي هو
اخر شخص في في الجدع نفسه انا العيله
كالتالي اللي صار معها على 12 تم تجري في
المنزل بالكامل تم استهدافه مره اخرى
باربع صواريخ وتم استهدافه
جرافات الاحتلال قامت بسحب كل الردم وفي
الشارع وحطته على البيت مع علم انه
الاصابات اللي طلعت هذا مع قوه الانفجار
خرجت من بره المنزل وبنت عمي الدبابه طلعت
فوقيها حسب روايه اخوها انا ما قدرت اصل
اكثر من مره للبيت صرت احاول اني اشيل حد
انقذه ما قدرتش كان الطخ علي مباشر انا
واربع شباب قدرنا بس الروح انا اطالب
الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر بفتح ممر
امن ان اقول انا ال جتت انا قبل يعني احنا
وصلنا لقينا صوت مناشده من تحت نعم ان انا
بس بدي مناشده اني اقدر اجيب احد من
العائله عندك هدول من العائله طبعا في
النسايب وجايين انا هي اللي تذكرتهم بس في
50 مجهولين اللي هم اطفال انا مش عارفهم
مين هم الحم اذا مجزره كبيره بحق سكم طبعا
هذه الكشوفات هي نعم اه هذه الكشوفات هي
اسماء الشهداء الذين تم حصرهم هذه اباده
جماعيه لعائله كامله تتعرض لها في مدينه
غزه هذه ليست العائله الاولى من قبل قوات
الاحتلال ابادت الكثير من عائلات ومسحت من
السجل المدني هذا الوضع في داخل مدينه غزه
ولازال الكثير مجهولون اسفل هذه الانقاض